you know i suppose it's kind of fitting
the fact that every time i talk about
this sort of thing
i do my initial video and then it just
results in
all this splash damage and other things
that come up that now i need to address
these too
[Music]
hey there folks so uh as you
probably have guessed this is in a way a
bit of a follow-up to
the videos i made on joss whedon and
gina carano though a little bit more on
joss whedon because what i'm going to
talk about is more applicable to his
work
than it is caranos and the mandalorian
one of the things that i found started
getting regularly brought up
in the comment sections of that video
was concerns
about basically everyone else involved
in whedon's work
who wasn't him so to take something that
was
his idea and his concept and he ran the
show
something like buffy the vampire slayer
is it
unfair or are we causing damage to
people who don't deserve it if there is
some sort of grand call to
cancel and never have buffy the vampire
slayer again
or to not re-watch or to talk about it
as a subject
given that there are many other artisan
professionals
who poured their heart and souls into
that did work that they're proud of
and may even still be getting residuals
off of it
this is the kind of topic that i have
very deliberately
avoided trying to broach and i've
avoided it in a couple of ways
one is in the fact that in those videos
and here now
i have stressed very hard i am
not calling for anybody
to disengage from these
fandoms from these creative works i have
talked about whether or not i intend to
disengage from them
and in most of the cases the answer has
been yes to some degree but i have been
as clear as i could that i'm not trying
to set an example
that other people should be living up to
it's simply the conclusion i came to
for myself so that's the first thing
the other thing is i have very
deliberately and flat out
said that i was avoiding this topic back
when i did my
video on problematic creators
and when i did that topic i deliberately
chose
authors of prose novels in that case it
was jk rowling
orson scott card and hp lovecraft and
the reason i picked them is because
while there are some other people
involved in a novel there's an
editor a publisher somebody does the
cover art etc
ultimately the primary beneficiary of
the success
of a novel is going to be the author
they are the ones who are almost solely
responsible for it
they are the ones who are going to
benefit from its success more than
anybody
else so the reason i did that there was
because it was
very clean and i really wanted to focus
on the philosophical aspects not get
stuck in the quagmire of the logistics
of more collaborative art forms
like film or
television but it got brought up enough
that i feel like i need to talk about it
in some way
and this is going to be tricky for me to
talk about because
like so many things i don't have a
definitive
the board it's this or it's this
answer for you it is always going to
come down
to a lot of specifics but i did want to
sort of air that concern because i think
there's a lot of
legitimacy behind it but i also think
that
while it's not necessarily
a bad faith argument to make i've seen
it deployed
elsewhere in a way that is actually more
harmful than it
is probably meant to be i will come back
to that but first let me draw the one
definitive
hard line that i'm going to draw
over this which is that i think there is
a conversation to be had
about anyone who worked with
a problematic creator prior to
their issues or whatever it is they did
or believe that
is causing the problem prior to that
becoming public any work they did
before that is certainly open for
conversation and discussion that's what
i'm going to focus on here
but i'm going to draw a hard line and
say anyone who chooses voluntarily
continue to work with
and or employ that creator after
everything has gone public
they don't get to claim collateral
damage they are
will willingly accepting and taking
on board the baggage that this creator
carries
now a good example of where this comes
up is with someone like roman polanski
the accusations against him are decades
old and basically anyone who has chosen
to work with him
since he fled the country decades ago
is doing so knowing full
well what he was accused of
what he fled the country to avoid
prosecution for and has decided that
that doesn't bother them enough to stop
them from working with him
similarly with woody allen now
does that mean that we have to cancel
anyone who ever
has worked with them even after that no
again i don't really call for
cancellations or boycotts but i am
saying
that you don't get to claim innocent
bystander
if you know the baggage and you are
voluntarily choosing to get involved
with it
you know the hazards of working with
this person you chose to do it anyway
so you're not exempt from any fallout
that may or may not
come your way as a result of that so
having established that we are
not dealing with giving the benefit of
the doubt with anyone who works
with these sorts of creators after their
issues are known
let's back up and talk about things like
buffy the vampire slayer
the x-men movies with someone like brian
singer and while joss whedon is far from
the
only sort of case of this you know there
are other plenty high-profile
directors or show runners or stars who
are big enough names that they
were executive producers and something
you know the
film or the tv show got made on the back
of
their involvement with it there are
plenty of them out there
but i am going to largely focus on joss
whedon not because i'm trying to pile on
but simply because that's the one people
are talking about the most right now
and i think it it's going to help the
conversation for me to focus primarily
on one
instance but just realize what i'm
talking about extrapolates out to
every time it applies so what we're
talking about here
is sort of each individual person's
because again
this will be your call and people are
making their calls on this and their
ability to engage
with something like buffy the vampire
slayer or any other of joss's works
at this point now the first thing is
i am personally of the opinion and i've
gone on record
that you cannot separate the artist from
the art
and for the purposes of this video even
though we're talking about collaborative
art forms i'm still focusing on the
primary creators i.e
the person without whom this property
would not exist at all
so to bring up somebody else i mentioned
you could make the argument
that the first x-men movie would have
still happened without brian singer he
was the director
but fox was going to make that movie no
matter what buffy the vampire slayer as
a
concept and as a show would never have
existed without joss whedon
with the situation like that you cannot
just divorce the artist from the art
in a collaborative art form there are
times when
well honestly if we knew the full
history and beliefs of literally
everyone involved in every piece of
collaborative art
television video games movies etc
there's gonna be somebody
somewhere involved with the thing who is
going to have said or done or believe
things that you find disagreeable
but the amount of weight that that
carries
is going to generally going to be
dependent on how much
influence does that person have on the
final product
because if i find out that say an uh
an actor who's basically a glorified
extra who's got like one scene with a
couple of lines
in some movie has sex offenses in their
history
i'm not really liable to
just can the entire movie say no never
going to take part
however if i find out that there
is an actor like that on set and the
director pushed for their hiring and was
aware of that history and put them
in scenes with the kind of people that
they had allegations of
abusing then yeah i am going to judge
that and yes that did
in fact happen that was shane black's
predator movie where that happened
so again even when dealing with
smaller uh contributors
it really does come down to
what extent are the major creative
forces
aware how much are they overlooking
how much are they culpable for so with
someone like joss whedon
we're talking about the toxic work
environment and the abusive behavior
towards
numerous co-stars at the time of
recording
i think we're up to about six or seven
people either giving specific details of
things he had
done or said to them or who
um verifying the general atmosphere
that he created on set and saying that
they believe and stand by
their co-stars and co-workers i say six
or seven at time of recording it's
probably higher by the time you see this
video
so he fostered this entire environment
but at the same time
what you love about the film while he
did touch it
and you are going to have to figure out
to what extent you are prepared to
grapple with that
it also involves wonderful acting
from many great actors
good effects work good fight
choreography
good music these are all people
whose work risks being denigrated and
basically going down with the ship
because of the issues with joss whedon
and that is a fair and valid point and
in addition to that
it can be an element of the attempt by
fandoms to
reclaim something this is obviously
something that we've seen
um attempt to happen with things like
the harry potter franchise
where the fandom or at least a very
significant portion of the fandom
is very even though while they continue
to engage with it it's very quick to
distance themselves from jk rowling call
out her beliefs and to
try and make the fandom as
self-contained a thing as possible
she may have created what brought them
together but she does not dictate
how they now engage with it and so we're
probably gonna start to see something
similar happen
with joss whedon and the and well
all of his works but again buffy is sort
of what i'm going to focus on here
and sort of a way to kind of reclaim
that is to put
the focus of what you love on things
other than his contributions which again
are going to be there no matter what you
do but you can zero in on
the acting on the scripts written by
people who weren't
him on the comedic timing the action
scenes
all sorts of stuff there are plenty of
elements that you can
find joy in that do not necessarily
mean that you are praising him so that's
another way to
shift your focus to continue to engage
with it and sort of
keep enjoying buffy but
you know work on um avoiding the
aggrandizing
of the creator and of course there are
all
there are also people who will make an
effort
to grapple with his work
in a way that acknowledges
how the failings we are learning about
him as a human being
actually seeped into his work the
unintentional
aspects of himself that was put into his
work in addition to the intentional ones
and my hat goes off to anyone who is
prepared to try and grapple with that
that's a lot to parse and it's a lot to
try and tackle and do well
empowered anyone who's willing to try
but
i do want to caution people
about leaning on this idea of
well if we cancel this what about all
the other people
whose work gets ignored because
we can look to something like the video
game industry
and some of the frequent things that go
on there right now
as an example of how this mentality
well-intentioned though it may be
can instead end up harboring a continued
abusive environment
for those very people that you're trying
to protect
if you don't know what i'm talking about
within the video game industry
abusive working conditions are honestly
almost the norm especially with any
large company what's known as the triple
a video game industry
and i'm gonna try and not get too far
into the weeds on this but
typical issues involve things like what
is called crunch
crunch times where you know we got we
need all hands on deck sort of thing
which have a tendency to mean that
people are working
up to 80 or sometimes even 100 hour
weeks
are not getting paid proper overtime for
doing so
even though no one deliberately says you
need to work these extra hours or you
will get fired
it is still understood that if they are
not putting in as many extra hours as
their co-workers that they are liable to
be replaced
this is a very damaging and
harmful culture for a lot of people on
the lower end of the totem pole
within that industry and when that gets
called out
or in even more egregious examples a
company like
ubisoft which has
high end executives who horrible
horrible things about their treatment of
their employees are coming out
there are people who say fans
who say well we still have to buy the
games because we have to support the
developers the people who made it
saying that we can't abandon this
because it'll hurt the victims you're
not
saving them you're perpetuating the
workplace because you are rewarding
the company that is working them to
death
and that's one of the weird nuances that
is really hard to parse
with something like buffy where i'm
fairly secure in saying that a lot of
the stars
get some form of residual checks
every time it is aired on television or
picked up for a new streaming service or
there's a new
uh home video release or what have you
so they do get something
from that but unless you know
everybody's contract
unless you know who's gonna benefit and
who isn't
then i i'm very antsy about hearing that
kind of defense deployed
in situations like joss whedon and i can
certainly tell you that none of the
ground level people
you know the the grips the camera people
set dressers makeup
none of them are getting residuals the
only people are going to get residuals
are going to be people like the headline
stars
and i don't want to go so far as to
suggest that
claims to defend them and their works
and their residual
checks are being made in bad faith i
don't want to go so far as to say that
anyone who says that is just deploying
it as an excuse to not give up something
that they like
that can and does happen but i don't
believe that everyone who says that sort
of thing
is that way i i honestly do not i've
seen some very good very passionate
defenses of this perspective from people
who
i admire and respect and believe that
they are honest in their position
and they are and i also believe that
they are introspective enough to
have considered the sorts of things that
i'm talking about
but again my concern is
this idea of well we can't
cancel something because of the
collateral damage
because this is the thing that came up
in
both the joss whedon and the gina carano
video
ultimately it's about money
the reason these people are being
removed
from the positions and the work that
they were doing
or may have trouble finding work in the
future
is not because of a moral stance and i'm
not saying fans aren't taking one they
are
but i'm saying the people who actually
write the paychecks who decide whether
or not these
individuals are employed who decide
whether or not to hire them in future
they only care about the
money
and ultimately if
they go through the calculations
of well okay this person's controversial
this problem has happened with them in
the past but
hey people are still buying their
product and i'm not saying that's going
to happen with joss whedon
i'm not saying if you keep watching
buffy the vampire slayer on whatever
streaming service is currently on
that suddenly he's gonna be allowed to
run a film set again and be abusive
towards actors again i i am not saying
that
do not twist me on that
however that general mentality
of as long as the money is coming
in is at the root of why
whedon was in a position of power
for as long as he was
and i cannot help but feel that
making a defense of
we can't cancel it it sounds like
talking about the banks too big to fail
okay but if you're going to continue to
prop it up you have to be very careful
about how you do it
because if you just say well we can't
let this sink and disappear and vanish
but don't do the introspective and put
the caveats and put the asterisk
next to joss whedon's name that needs to
be there
forever then it doesn't incentivize
these situations getting better
it continues to perpetuate the kind of
environment
where these people will continue to be
protected which is a huge part
of what i found very powerful about
charisma carpenter's statement
about joss whedon the specifics that she
cited
were terrible but it troubles me that
people got very
fixated on those specifics
and seemed to gloss over the fact that
she pointed out
as did ray fisher before her
that he was protected
coddled and rewarded by the people who
had the ability to stop
him and the only thing those people care
about is money
and allowing these things could to
continue to be profitable
you run the risk of perpetuating that
system and those people and that
mentality
again i say run the risk i'm not saying
you are doing that
you you right there who haven't gotten
rid of every single piece of buffy
paraphernalia that you have this is your
no i am
not and will not say that
but i'm saying be careful
because you may make the assessment
of something like buffy the vampire
slayer or firefly or
angel or dollhouse and come to the
conclusion
this still matters enough to me that i
wish to continue to engage with it
i wish to continue to talk about it i
wish to continue
to be part of the fandom that still
exists around it
that is fine be careful
about letting that become your default
mentality
every time something like this happens
these things need to be addressed on a
case-by-case basis because
no two instances are ever identical
so look inside yourself
consider the damage of
cancelling something like buffy
consider the damage of
leaving it as is consider those things
look inside yourself make your call
do your best to not judge other people
for theirs unless they're being
jerks you know if someone's being or
whatever but
come to your conclusion try to be fair
to people who might come to a different
one
than you do but also be
careful about letting that thought
process having gone through it once
just become a template that you apply to
each
other instance that this happens because
i said before this is going to keep
happening
be prepared to do the work that's
another thing i've said before
processing on this stuff sucks
it really really
sucks and doing the work
is never fun but that is always what i'm
going to push for
that is why i don't tell you what to do
or what to think
i try to the best of my ability to give
you things to take into account
so that when this video is over you can
consider
for yourself the things that i've said
the information and the knowledge and
the feelings that you already had
and process it and think about it
and not just default to an answer
because that answer applied in a
previous situation
so i think that's going to be it now
this is not a sponsored video however
i would like to shout out hi ho
silverworks
you'll find a link down in the
description they made this
uh particular design uh and
i actually have a number of their
designs i love this hoodie this was my
first crop top hoodie
something i never had before and like i
kind of love it
they have wonderful things they're a
terrific
artist with wonderful designs available
on their site i would encourage you to
check them out
and you can also find them on tick tock
for some fun content there as well
i should probably plug the patreon which
is how i cover my bills
and is what keeps this entire thing up
and running
even if you're not able to do that like
share subscribe they all help me out
this stuff sucks when it happens
but i want you to remember
you are beautiful you are valid
and you are loved you are the council
i am just running the meetings and until
next time hopefully on a more enjoyable
topic
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]